good-evening reject nation and good
morning India hey guys doing i'm greg
alba gregory fabulous he i prepared that
[ __ ] we're listening to a lot in songs
just a second ago and then I put on Will
Smith's just the two of us because he's
gonna destroy Robin Williams the genie
before we hop into this a lot in trailer
that we've been waiting around for hours
for today I wanted to mention to you
guys that we are on the Stardust app
like many a youtuber over there we post
30-second reactions for any film TV show
or trailer that includes a lot of random
mini sketches that we occasionally do
this is not a sponsored video but people
might get mad at us thinking it is ha ha
ha ha let's do this I've heard this
movie's gotten a lot of crap for
controversial castings not enough why
people in front or behind yeah man we
need more white people people who look
like me how am I gonna get into this how
is the upsetting part of this film
innocence 550 a.m. because it was
reported is gonna drop at 6:00 this
morning
and then 9:00 and then when that's when
hours later we're here let's do it this
better be the coolest trailer all time
good a dune
no offense
[Music]
[Music]
empire Yago still voiced by Gilbert
Godfrey let's hope so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
hey I could have played a Latin dude you
would've made a great ally I would have
been a perfect delight and I'm just
saying I like I said Will Smith Aladdin
in the covers well Disney's done it
again
they have taken a cartoon for real life
watch it oh god yeah I love this
animated movie I forgot how much I liked
this animated movie listening to the
song before the trailer drop I was like
man I really love these songs and I
forgot my love for Aladdin yeah it's
pretty great cuz he was the one
character from Disney that I thought I
could be ruff rat Street you look great
in a little vest with the feds yeah yeah
this is a thousand percent what Disney's
already been doing and you know what
that trend is working beauty like why
fix something when it ain't broken see
what I want to happen now is I hope that
we start going back and making 2d
animated remake tons of live-action pop
like adding music yeah I want to see you
in Reverse but yeah I mean like if some
people have complained about this trend
and I get it whatever same time lian's
of other people who are cool and the
thing is like I watch this and I was
maybe even a little cynical about just
cuz I was like why like what about this
movie says Guy Ritchie would like that's
got one thing I don't know but yeah just
like sitting there watching the images
like yeah I just got swept up like it's
weird to get swept up in like a teaser
but you know that opening shot with like
the really long perspective sand dune
you see the camels and stuff I'm guiding
him to go get the lamp it's a good tea
scene I was hoping we'd get one look at
Wilson I know me too especially cuz Will
Smith is the one who put that little
tease out that the trailer was coming
today that have a taste of Will Smith
yeah and I think he thought he was gonna
be in the trailer as well I'm just upset
that they did not cast a white guy to
play Aladdin I know where's Dan Stevens
man he should play every single one of
the princes where's Finn Jones
I was just waiting I really realized
that Danny Rand impersonation yeah yeah
we didn't see the carpet we didn't see a
boob we didn't see Jafar this whole
trailer talk is gonna be all yeah we
didn't see the whole entire movie we
didn't see the tiger guy I heard that
the guys who did music for lala land
they wrote I think like a couple of
songs maybe yeah like one song or two
that it's brand-new for the movies I'm
really looking forward to that
that's always the fascinating part with
these remixes like is the one song that
they added in like yeah that gonna be
great news it gonna match the soundtrack
and stuff I have a strong feeling that
most of this will just feel like the
animated movie the thing though that's
gonna undoubtedly feel different and
this is why it was the main thing I was
looking forward to seeing was Will Smith
as the genie
yeah just like Suicide Squad that's
gonna be Wilson well that's the thing is
Robin Williams the genie was so
distinctive only Robin Williams could do
that and there's no way in hell any of
anyone can emulate or replicate it all
what Robin Williams did as the genie
except John Bailey except John Bailey I
hope you're watching Will Smith's take
would just be undoubtedly is different
and he should have it yeah and I'm like
everything else might just be freaking
the Aladdin cartoon yeah you know I
don't even know whose is the I'll go
talk in this it wasn't talking about
Strahler curious about that too ya know
I'd be very disappointed if he didn't I
would imagine that he would the you know
fixtures and stuff in Beauty the Beast
still talking and this is a really
ethnically diverse cast which I'm really
happy they stuck to their guns and did
that so like it's a perfect meld you
know yeah and it's so they this and
Mulan has to not be full of whites
yeah that would help the inevitable
Pocahontas Oh God which would be so
awkward you don't want to see they made
that happen yeah I'm just so happy we
waited all day thirteen hired a
we're both a little bit slap-happy or
literally things that could have been
pictures for the internet you really
could have released this as a story
would that is true because every one of
these images is designed to be like
screenshot it and made your facebook
cover photo yeah it's the animated
Arabian Nights the people riding the
camels Aladdin going inside the cave
with the talking tiger face I don't know
what that's called i Fred's been a long
time says in the movie I just recapping
the old yeah I mean III wonder if maybe
like the stuff in the city like when you
really get into like Aladdin's life
might call upon some guy ritchie's you
know like street style execute ease but
like part of me wonders if this isn't
Disney just going here Guy Ritchie you
hold this camera I think that's what
it's good that's what it's like there's
no way like Guy Ritchie has not had a
really good film and quite like it's
been a while they see love Aladdin I
think yeah so I think for this one it's
gonna be a lot of studio input and Guy
Ritchie going cool can I make my
gangster film now with the money you
gave me had a pretty interesting cast
for that anyway and and Will Smith and
you know creatively controlling this
project I'm surprised he's got to have a
new song in this somewhere right I think
the genies gonna rap I think the genies
gonna write I think that's always gonna
prep miss for with his Will Smith
channel going on the world cup I think
you're prepping us that he's gonna he's
gonna have you but perhaps Papa I just I
just I just imagine the credits
beginning and then you know some kind of
whimsical yeah you know Magic Lantern
wrap hahaha Aladdin Aladdin Arabians
this is the best review you'll get and
all of YouTube right now killing the
game you're killing the games as well
worth the ways channels alive and I
wanted to give a patron of the day
shout-out to a lady start of our patron
page name
separa she hit me up on twitter saying i
hope you guys are covering this tonight
followed by a lot of swear words i says
of course we're gonna cover it tonight
so Rosa thanks for keeping us on top of
our game
you were one of the sexiest woman alive
if not the sexiest and you have a
beautiful family all your children are
gonna grow to be super rich and super
famous and you'll retire and live off
their fame and fortune I want you to
know that thank you for being the kind
hearted lady you are and I know that one
of these days you will be a Playboy
cover model when playboy decides to do
that again and you'll have a review in
the part where it's for the articles
because you like to see all right
subscribe click notification bells
they're real and we have stuff bye bye